من جهه اخرى قال مالك مجموعه فاغنر
الروسيه يافغيني بروجين ان عدد قوته كان
يجب ان يبلغ 23 ضعفا لحجمها الحالي وفقا
لمنهجيه الحسابات العملياتيه وتكتيكيه
التي اقرتها هيئه الاركان الروسيه وارجع
بروجوجل ذلك الى ما سماه الخيانه
وما يجب اضافته هناك مفهوم منهجيه
الحسابات العملياتيه والتكتيكيه والذي
وافقت عليه هيئه الاركان ووفقا لهذه
المنهجيه كان من المفترض ان يكون عدد قوات
فاجنر اكبر بثلاث وعشرين مره وكان يجب ان
يكون عدد الاسلحه 27 ضعفا واعطيت لنا
القذائف بنسبه 11 ونصف في المئه وهذه
ارقام دقيقه تماما وموثوقه وفقا لجميع
اوامر هيئه الاركان العامه استخلص
استنتاجين كفاءتنا والخيانه التي حلت بنا
الان يمكننا التحدث عن ذلك